et pour en savoir plus sur ce tout nick
v est tenté de répondre aux accusations
sur l'incapacité de la russie à produire
assez de vaccins faisons un tour dans l'
usine qui produit spoutnik d immersion à
saint-pétersbourg dans l' usine
pharmaceutique bio cad c'est un
reportage de vera goffman passer de deux
à six millions de kits par mois après
une modernisation février les usines
pharmaceutiques bio cad un des ces deux
centres certifiés sur les territoires
russe pour fabriquer le vaccin s'apprête
à tripler sa production de se cultiver
les spéculations de la presse
occidentale sur l'incapacité de la
russie à produire suffisamment de
vaccins même pour ses propres besoins
suscite une réflexion philosophique chez
la direction de bio cad
vous savez j'aime beaucoup cette
citation du mahatma gandhi d'abord ils
vous ignorent ensuite ils se moquent de
vous après ils vous combattent et enfin
vous ne gagnez nous avons fait face à
cette situation en mettant au point des
médicaments biotechnologiques et
maintenant mettant point tel où tel
vaccin
j'estime que c'est une sorte de je sais
que cela ne correspond pas à la réalité
parce que la russie déploie des efforts
immenses pour faire en sorte que le
vaccin soit accessible en premier lieu
aux citoyens russes nous avons la chance
de visiter le saint des saints de
lézinnes son laboratoire
pas question de se promener dans le
laboratoire
onze civils du coup nous sommes obligés
de mettre des costumes des ours polaires
je suis prête la production se doublent
ainsi bio cad reçoit du matériel
cellulaire et viral depuis l'institut
gamaleya concepteur du vaccin puisse ont
développé des cellules qui sont ensuite
infectées avec du matériel viral
après la production du virus plusieurs
étapes de purification de celui ci sont
effectués
ce n'est pas un boisson il faut surtout
pas le boire c'est l'échantillon du
futur vaccin
une fois que le vaccin est prêt il est
mise en doute hey dites moi s'il vous
plaît à quel coût et le risque d'une
erreur humaine et il éliminer on ne peut
éliminer la possibilité d'une erreur
humaine mais nous l'avons réduite au
maximum chaque machine à ces points de
contrôle
ainsi s'il n'y a pas de notice alors
tout le paquet est mis au rebut
auparavant la machine contrôler 100% de
la fabrication et le département qualité
vérifiée un flacon par paquet enfin le
tout est mis sur une palette par un
automate et la palette est transporté à
l'entrepôt nous tous sera congelée lui
caméra devais rester chaque flacon avant
qu'elle soit envoyée à l'emballage en
cas d' amour
défaut le plateau en coupe sous rejeté
par la machine alors que l'agencé
européenne des médicaments tarde à
donner son feu vert pour l'utilisation
de spoutnik vais sur le territoire de le
le vaccin russe est déjà enregistrée
dans 60 pays pour une population de 3
milliards de personnes et la russie
ambitions de remplir tous ses
engagements